-My first guest is
a talented comedian
and the host of
"The Daily Show."
Tickets to see him live on the
"Back to Abnormal" tour
are available at trevornoah.com.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Trevor Noah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Trevor Noah ♪
♪ Back another time ♪
♪ Cannot arrest him ♪
♪ Even though
he was born a crime ♪
♪ Now he got to know ♪
♪ He sees it ♪
♪ On "The Daily Show," yeah ♪
-Trevor Noah!
-Oh, yeah!
-Oh, look at that.
How does that feel?
-Wow!
-That's got to feel good, huh?
-Come out to a standing "O"?
Come on. They love you, man.
-It's a little --
It's a little overwhelming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's wonderful. Thank you.
But it's a little --
It's a little overwhelming.
-It is, right?
-I've been small for very long.
-I know. You really have.
-You know what
I feel like is happening
right now with the pandemic?
I almost feel like, you know,
the dinosaurs
probably thought about,
like, the world like this,
like, when the asteroid hits.
And they were like, "Boom,"
and then they were like, "Whoa!"
And then they were
like, "Oh, we survived."
And they were like,
"Let's carry on with our lives."
Let's go to 'The Tonight Show.'"
-Yeah.
-And then the cloud came,
and they were like, "Oh, man.
We got confident too quickly."
-I know.
-I don't know. I don't know.
-I feel like
we're on the baby steps --
-And I hope so.
I hope -- Baby steps in
the right direction.
Either way, we're having fun
along the way.
-We're having fun.
-Yeah.
-We're getting back to
wearing masks.
We're doing the right thing.
-You know what my thing is, man?
I go like, "This is what
the vaccine is supposed to be."
I was like, "I got the vaccine"
and I was like,
"I'm now going to have fun."
So I was like,
"I'm going to test the vaccine."
First place I went to,
I went to Miami.
That was the first thing I did.
I was like,
"I've got the vaccine."
"I'm going to go Miami,
because I want to see if
the vaccine works."
And I went to Miami, and --
-You tested it out.
-That was great.
Didn't get COVID.
Got other diseases,
but didn't get COVID.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's Miami, yeah.
-Yeah.
-That's right.
-But it's good to be back, man.
-I am happy and thankful
that you're back here,
because, you know,
I saw that you did
stand-up over the summer for
the first time, 'cause --
-Yeah, it was crazy, man.
-Because I've been
watching your show.
It's been great, but it's been
you in a corner of your house.
-Yes. It sounds
very depressing, doesn't it?
-But it's very funny.
It's very funny.
And I watch it and then I go,
"Oh, you went out and
did stand-up."
And I go -- When did you decide,
"Oh, I'm doing --
I have to go out and do --"
-I didn't decide.
So, what happened was,
no comedian really decided.
So, Dave Chappelle
decided, right?
He was like, "I'm doing comedy."
And then he started phoning
people and he's like,
"You're doing comedy."
And I was like,
"No, I'm staying at home."
And he's like, "No, you're not."
And then he, like,
started doing comedy in, like,
a cornfield in Ohio.
-That's correct.
-Which I thought was,
like, a joke.
Like, even when he said it,
I was like, "Ha!
That's a nice concept."
And he's like,
"No, I'm being serious."
And then I got there,
and it was an actual --
I thought it was like --
You know when people say
things -- "It's in a field" --
you think it, like,
it just means in an open --
No, it was a field.
-You were in a field.
-Just driving in Ohio.
It was like farm, farm,
cow, cow, cow,
farm, farm, corn, corn, corn,
Dave Chappelle.
-Wow.
-And then it was just like
we're doing comedy in a field.
And then, every time, he would
pop up, and he'd just be like,
"You're doing comedy again."
And then I would just
do the comedy.
So I didn't really decide --
And I'm grateful to him,
because, like, I think a lot of
comedians needed one comedian
to be like, "Poke, poke.
You're going.
You're gonna do the show."
-And did you have a little bit
of an act in your head
or you just go, like -- No.
-I mean, it's been crazy, like,
because you don't see
the people.
Do you know what I mean?
And then,
when you see the people --
Like, because the masks are on,
and you don't know
what's happening
behind anybody's faces.
-That's true.
-And, like, our whole lives,
we've been told that masks
are, like, the bad guy.
Bad guys wear masks.
You know what I mean?
Now it's like --
Now good guys wear masks.
You know what I mean?
-It's the opposite of
anything --
-Yeah, it's like the complete
opposite of everything now.
And now you don't know
if people are smiling.
So, like, everyone has
to do, like, extra work.
[ Laughter ]
-There's a lot of eye work.
-"I'm very happy to see you!"
-Yeah, a lot of eye work.
I got a picture of you
out that night,
and here's you, Chris Rock,
and Dave Chappelle.
-That was wild, man.
-I mean --
-That was -- But you see,
this is -- So, this is where --
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is where
I actually got tricked.
So, Dave said he was
doing a show
that I should come and watch.
And, so, I rode
a sissy bike there.
That's how confident I was that
I wasn't performing, right?
Because you don't ride a bicycle
when you're going to,
like, perform at a show.
That's, like -- As a comedian --
Because the thing is,
if you go to a show, you don't
know if it's going to go
well or if it's
going to go badly, right?
And so if it goes badly,
you don't want to be
riding a bicycle home.
-No, it's very sad.
That's the most depressing
thing in the world.
-You just want to be
in, like, the back of a car
being like, "That was terrible."
You don't want to ride
a bicycle home.
-No.
-So I rode a bicycle there.
And then he was like,
"Oh, you're performing."
And then I was like, "But I rode
a bicycle here, Dave."
Like, "I can't bomb
and then ride my bike home."
-But, yeah, again,
it was amazing.
I mean, it's Dave Chappelle
and Chris Rock,
and the three of us are onstage
and we're working material
and we're trying,
and the audience was so happy
to be out again.
It was just, yeah, it was --
Those are dream moments in life.
-Everyone must ask,
but do you get advice from
Dave Chappelle or Chris Rock?
-Oh, yeah, definitely.
If you just listen to them,
it's advice.
You know, like Chris Rock --
I used to work
seven days a week,
and I was, like, proud of it.
I was like,
"I work seven days a week.
I work seven days a week,
every day."
And then Chris Rock was like,
"You're going to be
the most unfunny comedian
of all time."
And I was like, "What?"
And he's like,
"You work all the time."
He's like, "Comedy comes
from life, you know?"
And he was like,
"If you work every day,
what is your comedy gonna --
Your comedy is going to start
being about comedy."
And I was like, "Oh, man.
I never thought about that."
-That's wild.
-Yeah.
And, like,
he's told me so many things.
Chappelle has given me advice.
Chappelle will
give me advice, though.
He'll go,
"Here's all the advice,"
and then, at the end of it,
he goes,
"But don't take my advice,
'cause, I mean..."
-That's interesting, right?
And then,
"Don't take my advice."
-Yeah, his advice is always
like, "Don't listen to me."
-But you did have some time off.
-I did, man.
I tried to use it as much --
I tell everybody,
man, we don't know what life
is going to be like
or not be like,
so use the little opportunities
that you get
to just live a little bit more,
you know,
even if it means walk--
I've walked in more parks in
New York than I ever did
in like the six years
since I moved here.
Now I'm like, "There's a park."
I walk in it.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
Before, I was like,
"Ew, a park.
Why am I taking the park?"
Now I --
Like, I do touristy things.
You know how many people
live in the city,
and they've never seen
any of the sights?
-No.
-We take it for granted.
-We really do, yeah.
People go like, "Do you go see
the Statue of Liberty?"
I'm like, "No.
I don't see that every day.
I know it exists. It's here."
-You see?
And that's what
I'm talking about.
So I've tried to just, like,
live a bit more.
And that's what I'm been doing
during this period,
just, like, trying to live
a little it more,
to appreciate
what we didn't have.
-You're doing your
"Back to Abnormal" Tour,
which is --
You're gonna be in London.
You're going all over.
-Yes.
I'm going to London tonight,
and then start the show.
So, it's going to be at
the O2 Arena.
Really excited. It's sold out.
-Wow!
-And, yeah, I mean, like,
the U.K. is just open.
That's how -- That's, like --
I love how every country
is just going with
their own thing.
Do you know what I mean?
No, because, like,
Americans are like,
"Alright, look, guys,
we're sort of open,
but we're not open fully."
And then, in the U.K.,
they were like,
"We're closed, we're closed,
we're closed, we're closed.
we're closed."
Then they're like,
"Alright, it's open.
We don't care anymore.
We're open.
It's all open.
This is how it's gonna be now.
We're all open.
This is what we're doing.
-And "Daily Show" comes back --
-Yeah.
-When are you back?
-Next week, Monday, we're back.
-Next Monday, you're back.
-Yeah. We're back next Monday.
-I think the show that you were
doing was amazing, by the way.
You did great work
when we needed you.
We needed people to
come out and entertain,
and you were right there.
And you were like, "Yep,
I got to do it from my house.
I'm going to do it,"
and you just did it.
I thought that was awesome.
-Thank you, man.
-Props to you for doing that.
-I had a lot of fun. Yeah.
-You got creative
and really good.
But now, are you
gonna go back to the suits?
-Well, we can't go back
anywhere right now
because we're in
the middle of --
So it's like, "Are we going to
try find a space --"
I think my neighbors
are happy, you know?
Because, like,
my neighbors were like,
"So, this is, like, where you
make the show now?"
I'm like, "Yeah.
This is me making the show."
I'm just, like, the guy
screaming next door to you,
"Welcome back!"
-Crazy -- Yeah.
-The neighbors were just like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, you can go."
So, yeah, I'm figuring out
the pieces now.
It's going to be exciting.
Like, I'm trying new things.
I'm playing -- You know what?
I think what COVID
has done to me is,
it's made me a little
bit less afraid to fail in life,
because when COVID happened,
it took everything away from us.
Do you know what I mean?
It took away our friends.
It took away our opportunities.
It took away
so many people's jobs.
It took away dreams.
It took away aspirations.
And so now I feel ungrateful
not trying to live life
a little bit more because there
is life to be lived.
Does that make sense?
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Yeah, so now I'm just like --
-I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Have fun.
-I love that.
-Try it.
-We're going to have fun.
When we come back,
more with Trevor Noah.
Come on back.